c'est rendu compliqué pour les gens
c'est toujours une contrainte après une
contrainte
les gens font tellement de fois le tour
d'aider des pâtés de maisons pour se
trouver de sincèrement que ça pollue
quatre fois plus alors des citoyens vous
l'entendez du plateau mont royal en ont
assez de ces changement de politique
concernant les vignettes
hier il ya eu donc une assemblée à ce
sujet françois cormier des milliers de
personnes faut dire ont signé une
pétition et le maire coderre s'en est
mêlée aujourd'hui oui le mercredi requis
par contre faut le dire n'a pas précisé
quelle serait sa solution à lui
il présentera nouvelle politique du
stationnement au cours des prochaines
semaines pour l'ensemble de la ville de
montréal s'est dit patrice effectivement
il ya des citoyens qui se sont présentés
à la séance du conseil d'arrondissement
du plateau mont royal hier mécontents
pétition à la main pour signifier à
l'administration de luc ferrandez qu'il
n'était pas d'accord avec ces vignettes
qui ont été installées à différents
endroits dans l'arrondissement je pense
notamment aux petits laurier ou 30 pour
environ 30% des stationnements ont des
vignes est maintenant parmi les les gens
qui sont allés parler hier vous l'avez
entendu juste juste avant ce direct
entre autres michel rivard l'auteur
compositeur interprète donc
l'administration de luc ferrandez qui
répond qu'elle va étudier tout ça mais
qu'il ya des changements qui seront
apportés par ce que l'administration de
monsieur coderre elle s'en mêlera au
cours des prochaines semaines bref je
laisse entendre luc ferrandez suivi de
dénis coderre
alors je vais commencer par utiliser
votre proposition attendre la cuve d'une
semaine à l'autre membre la politique
une réponse à votre question il faut pas
arriver de façon dogmatique dei crois ou
meurs
si vous pensez pas comme moi ben vous
avez pas raison c'est moi qui avais et
absolut et quand on fonctionne à coude
véritable cellule mais ça provoque des
pétitions de 1000 personnes
voilà parce que déjà avant cette
histoire des vignettes c'était un
problème sur le plateau vous avez
l'impression que ça amplifier ce
problème là que les gens ne peuvent plus
stationner à certaines à certains
endroits où il ne faisait avant quoi
exactement donc les citoyens qui disent
écoutez on pouvait
à tout le moins se stationner là pour
quelques heures ou encore les gens qui
venaient nous visiter à la maison
pouvait se stationner là avec des
vignettes ça complique entre autres la
possibilité d'avoir de la visite
finalement est ce même problème la
patrie se vit également dans rosemont
dans un certains secteurs rue de
normanville où là aussi une pétition qui
circule des citoyens qui sont mécontents
de voir des vignettes être ajouté je
vous laisse entendre l'un des résidents
de heureusement qu'on a rencontré
aujourd'hui on voit vraiment la raison
pour laquelle on implantera un système
de vignettes autrement que donner la
possibilité à des gens qui en ont les
moyens de se payer une place de
stationnement plus facilement que les
autres
je pense pas qu'on aurait vraiment de
raison d'avoir deux classes de citoyens
dans sur notre rue ceux qui ont les
moyens de se payer un stationnement puis
les autres qui vont devoir chercher et
vous l'avez peut-être vu sur les images
pas très sale et les affiches qui
avaient été vandalisés donc ces affiches
qui ont été installés pour signifier que
des vignettes sont nécessaires
maintenant on a demandé des entrevues
aujourd'hui pour avoir davantage de
précisions au maire du plateau mont
royal luc ferrandez ainsi qu'on merde
heureusement françois croteau qui n'ont
pas voulu accorder d'entrevue
mais voilà on y reviendra évidemment
merci françois au revoir